hey guys welcome to the reubin report
I'm the guy who designed the Obamacare
website Dave Rubin I've got Max Luger
and Bren Muer with me and yeah we're
going to start with Obamacare because
everybody's freaking out they should
have used Squarespace which is what I
told them in the first place uh the
website is not working and just to catch
you up real quick the government's back
to work or whatever it is that they do
uh remember they shut down for about 3
weeks because the house doop didn't
really want poor people to have health
insurance cuz that would destroy Freedom
uh the way I understand it and uh now
people are freaking because the website
is not working out and Kathleen silius
who is the health and human services uh
director I think director uh she was on
CNN with Sanjay Gupta last night
explaining some of the problems let's
take a look did say that he was angry
about this I mean do do you know when he
first knew that there was a problem well
I think it became clear fairly early on
uh the first couple of days
so not before that though not before
October 1st there was no concern at that
point either in the white house or at
HHS I think that we talked about uh
having testing uh going forward and if
we had an ideal situation and could have
built a product in you know a 5year
period of time we probably would have
taken five years but we didn't have five
years and certainly Americans who rely
on health coverage didn't have 5 years
for us to wait we wanted to make sure we
made good on this final implementation
of the law and again people can sign up
call center is open for business we've
had a,1 100,000 calls we've had 19
million people visit the website
500,000 accounts created and people are
shopping every day so people are signing
up and there's help in neighborhoods
around the country that people can have
a one-on-one visit with a train
Navigator and figure out how to sign up
so people are able to sign up all right
so there's a lot lot of just typical
prbs there I mean she's just giving you
answers that kind of maybe seem true I
thought the one thing that was really
interesting she said 1.1 million calls
to the center 19 million uh visits to
the website 500,000 accounts created as
if that was good does that seem like a
lot if 19 million people you guys are
web people if 19 million people went
there did only 500,000 mean to subscribe
I mean isn't that doesn't that show that
something's not working that's a
horribly low number I think that they
must the government must abide by
Facebook's internal motto that done is
better than perfect clearly clearly they
were happy with the it's a hard site to
put together too I mean it's a this is a
big a big project that we're taking on
so we have to don't we have to give a
little bit of credit and say a little
wiggle room and that thing to be able to
just launch it right away absolutely I'm
willing to go with the with the wiggle
room thing and well because you know the
next thing that she said was that we're
going to bring in our a team to fix this
so who did they bring in to start this
again I got two web techsavvy
technological people here who who do you
think they brought in in the first place
to get this team yeah the D where was Mr
T why wasn't the A Team coming in at the
first place I think it's a great
question now bring them in now but so
we'll see you know it's the Geniuses
coming in now yeah apparently like what
what I gleaned from that is that they've
been using the same sort of Technology
contractors for a really long time and
they've gotten sort of lazy in their
ability to code or something like that
they just haven't stayed up toate on
current Technologies which is kind of
you know awful you think about it same
contractors from like 1992 still
building all the sites right I'm pretty
sure they're using dialup to to get this
going I mean it's pretty awful what do
you guys make of this thing about where
she said you know we have if we had five
years to do this it would have been a
lot better but people need health
insurance now I mean they had at least a
year really how long does it take I'm
willing to grant them that this is a big
project but how long does it take to get
a website up and running and I think it
I mean it is a big project but it let's
be honest too it is just sort of a
signup form in the end so I do want to
give everybody sort of the benefit of
the doubt but it is kind of a even if
you just redirected them to another site
and then collected that little piece of
information so I I I don't know I want
to give them a benefit of the doubt but
at the same time it's a I mean Riot
could have built the technology for we
we should have and it would be a good
contast how many how many web people do
you have I've got one genius and I think
he could he could have done it but I
need him so don't try to take him he is
the a the government could pull like an
imminent domain thing and steal that's a
good point don't tell them that yeah but
I mean really though we're joking about
it but I mean if you think about it
there are sites that are streaming video
all day long literally millions and
millions of videos all day long and they
don't crash so isn't this like the worst
thing that could have happened to Obama
that that something that he his whole
signature policy is is proving to just
unravel right right in front of us yeah
it's it's genius that that you bring
that up I mean porn has always typically
pushed the envelope forward
technologically speaking so it's it's
funny maybe that's the A Team then is
the the porn that would be funny if all
the porn sites crash now because all The
Tech Guys
Valley right now exactly the people
behind PornHub yeah how do you know
PornHub that I've read about it in the
Atlantic PornHub in
that's. never crashes never what do you
guys think about this idea where she
said that you know it's it's now come
out that uh they knew for days that this
thing was crashing but that nobody told
Obama she said In that clip that we just
saw nobody told him for a couple days
that this was happening do you think
they purposely don't tell him anything
cuz I feel like this has been sort of a
cons istent thing so he can be like well
I didn't know so it's not my fault so I
feel like it's sort of like an
independence day remember when uh they
didn't tell the President Bill Pullman
about the aliens because it was
plausible deniability I feel like they
do a lot of that with Obama whose job
would it be to tell him though because
nobody wants maybe they just said who
wants to go tell the president nobody ra
their hand nobody does want to make that
make that call go down to the office
knock on the door and say you know the
website's not working right but
shouldn't shouldn't that guy at least be
fired the guy that's supposed to tell
him like how does that stuff not get to
the top well I mean this is one of the
great initiatives of his campaign you
know so like you'd think that he would
be a beta tester President Obama at
least right yeah yeah yeah but no beta
testing they didn't even get that far I
know uh all right but so so last
question on this how much of a big deal
should we make this I mean this thing
this thing look this is going to change
the way America is for the near future
and probably for the longterm future um
so should we grant them just all right a
couple weeks of website screwing us or
is this really a precursor to uh how the
whole
I mean for me you know I think it's such
an exciting thing that there's going to
be a lot of Americans who had never had
Healthcare before so for me it's like I
I I don't wanted to overshadow the fact
that this is a really great moment in in
our history where people who had never
been covered before are about to get
covered so I'm going to give it some
time I think that the detractors
certainly wanted something like this to
happen because it's easy for them to say
look we told you it doesn't work um but
you know websites crash all the time my
website crashes when we get insane
amounts of traffic when we're doing this
probably it's going to crash as well
watch YouTube right now yeah so I'm
giving it the benefit of the doubt
that's my that's my take yeah I I agree
with Brinn uh I think that uninsured
Americans have waited long enough for it
I think that like for them to work out
the Kinks You know it's it's it'll be
worth the wait yeah all right and final
thought on this you know the the
shutdown apparently cost $24 billion to
our economy so maybe we could have used
a little bit of that money for better
web programmers okay let's move on to
China because America is not the only
one that has problems China is going
through a completely Bonkers situation
right now they're calling it air pock
alypse uh a Chinese city called Harbin
uh is having crazy crazy smog we're
going to show you some video right now
and understand this is smog caused by
pollution not fog let's take a
look okay so again that is smog not fog
that is actual pollution just to put
some of this in perspective uh Harmon is
home to 11 million people which is about
the size of New York City uh their air
quality index score was a 500 uh they
tell us that every anything over 300 is
dangerous to humans New York City's on
an average day is about 50 uh I mean
this this is just is it hard to imagine
that humans are putting that kind of
stuff in the air isn't it awful yeah but
apparently like the states went through
you know a similar situation at the turn
of the Industrial Revolution you know
and I think that like China definitely
needs to figure it out cuz 500 sounds
awful I mean it's literally off the
chart uh well I think when you look at
these you know it's Max what you're
saying is that China does need a wakeup
call for environmental policies and so
my hope when you start to see images
like this is that the rest of the world
turns their attention and maybe it's a
kick in the butt the Chinese government
to take care of it we saw in London the
same thing 19 the50s there was a Great
Smog and that led to the Clean Air Act
so hopefully believe this is an
indication that this is going to also
kind of turn things around that's my
hope and I mean we had it right here in
LA and now the air quality is a lot
better than it used to be but it's part
of this though that China's just getting
to the point in their economy where we
were way back when so it's sort of it
it's almost disingenuous for us to tell
them to clean it up because they're just
doing what we did a little bit later
right I mean is it sort of unfair to to
now that we've cleaned ourselves up cuz
our econom is pass that point well
that's a lot of smog though and and
they're adding so many cars onto the
roads at all the time
there has to be a Tipping Point for it
and um you know when you start to see
what's happening with climate change and
extreme weather that we're seeing
everywhere there needs to be this wake
up from all the countries especially
indust and I think that today you know
just because of how easy and free
flowing information is around the world
like I think that they should learn from
our mistakes you know like they
shouldn't you know they should it's not
an excuse that they should just like
deal with a five you know 500 level air
quality it's horrible but isn't that one
of those things where like when we all
get together to talk about the
environment the United States always
wants to cap things lower because our
economy is different now and the
industrial the Nations that are blowing
up right now like China and India
they're like well we can't cuz we're
trying to get so you're saying it's like
the factories of the United States put
in China that sort of well I guess at
some level um all but if we're all
connected you know I mean if if our air
is all connected from this thing we have
to eventually and they say that we can
still see soot here that comes from
China too so or certainly what happened
in Japan with Fukushima now we're seeing
the same results of that here so we have
to be able to police some of that at
some so so actually the CH the Japan
thing's totally sidebar but we're
literally seeing radioactive water now
coming to our Shores so that should show
people that we're we're kind of
connected yeah absolutely yeah uh so
just to explain the the situation a
little bit more China gives free heating
to the people in the north using these
coal boilers and that's why this is all
happening in the north of China and not
in the South uh this was making me think
just on a personal level for our myopic
Little Lives that uh you know I go to
like Trader Joe's here in West Hollywood
and you know they don't give bags
anymore or you have to pay 10 cents for
a paper bag there's no plastic or
anything like that and you feel like
you're doing something good but then
when you see this do you realize that
actually you're just doing it for
yourself and that you know it's not re
it's not that you're really like the
little bag that you would have taken out
of Trader Joe's actually isn't saving
anybody but it's sort of making you have
to be hopeful that it's all making an
impact I mean that's the whole thing is
that we're we're we're in such a
dangerous place I think with climate
change and this extreme weather that
we're seeing that we cannot sort of be
defe about it right and so every step
that you do I think does matter um and
so that little bag does help out when
you look at countries like Rwanda that
banned plastic bags that country has
transformed itself you don't see any
trash on the streets anymore so it it
can work um but you know when you look
at what's happening in China with the
smog it's it's absolutely terrible even
if it doesn't specifically work with our
little bags and the little things that
we can do here in recycling and that
kind of stuff is there something that
just personally is good like taking sort
of a personal responsibility for what
you put into into the world or am I
being very uh yeah I mean spiritually
deep I mean yeah it's again like I think
it's not helpful in any way to have a
Deus mentality about it and to remember
that little shifts add up to one big
shift you know and to vote with your
wallet whenever you can when you're
checking out I mean whether or not you
choose a bag at checkout you know like
obviously our diets you know have a
large say in in you know the health of
the environment um so there's like
little things that we could do but yeah
I mean just because you know 11 million
people are are drowning in smog like we
can still do our over here yeah do you
guys think we're ever going to fight a
war over the environment you know like
if if these things keep getting worse
and because we're so connected right now
and if China let's say doesn't do
anything and this keeps getting worse
and the smog keeps coming us and
radioactive Waters coming to our West
Coast that actually we could end up
fighting a a true War to sort of control
resources and how uh countries put stuff
to I think it's I think it's already
happening I mean when you look at what
happened in Africa Lake Chad in the 70s
was one of the largest lakes in Africa
and now it's almost gone and those
climate refugees moved into darur which
then created what happened in South
Sudan so I mean it's happening right now
it's going to get worse I think
especially in the Nile and the valley
there and you know in the agricultural
belt um I think what's scary is that you
probably are going to see it in the
United States where people are fighting
states are fighting over resources and
who has access to certain Rivers so uh
you know I don't want to be alarmist
about it but I'm you know I'm worried
about it and I I want prediction which
two states are going to be the first to
fight in a war what's that going to be
probably California us and you know
we'll go against it'll be like LA versus
Las Vegas that's how it'll kind of well
it's going to be something involving
fracking right because they're going to
Frack from one state into another and
then just the whole State's going to
explode and then yeah oh my God yeah but
that's a whole other topic okay let's
move on uh Facebook have you heard about
that thing I just saw actually that Mark
Zuckerberg today they announced he made
$2.2 billion in uh 2012 so you know a
lot of people are on that Facebook uh
they just lifted their violent video ban
and this has a lot to do with beheadings
uh so basically people were posting all
these beheadings that were happening all
over the world mostly in the Middle East
uh and then in may they banned it and
they've been reviewing their policy and
as of yesterday uh they have lifted the
ban and now you can see beheadings on
Facebook again but we've got a quote
from Facebook
spokesman people share videos of these
events on Facebook to condemn them if
they were being celebrated or the
actions in them encouraged our approach
would be different we want to draw a
distinction between users who want to
share events that are important to them
and videos that are being celebrated and
shared for sadistic pleasure that's Matt
Steinfeld from Facebook all right so
they're making a clear distinction
between uh I guess bad beheadings and
and good beheadings or celebratory
beheadings or something I guess this
sort of goes to the nature of what is
Facebook and should it be just this
open- Source thing that anyone can put
anything on what do you make on this
about this flip yeah I mean I think that
um you know it's interesting that they
would take such a Firm Stance on on
violence when they've been so you know
equally firm against like you know
nudity and breastfeeding that whole
controvery we're going to get to that
yeah yeah um but I mean I guess it's
good if they if they want to if they're
allowing people to condemn violence in
their own you know weird way I
personally don't want to see any of that
on my Facebook news feed really so but
what about your Twitter feed would you
be more okay with it on Twitter because
I think this does go to the what why do
we use these things and how we use them
all differ I mean the thing is I I know
that it exists I mean I guess like you
know not everybody is as informed but um
but yeah I mean I think that uh I think
it's okay I think it's okay yeah all
right well let's take a look at some of
the other things that Facebook has
banned right now they're banning nudity
drug use pornography promotion of Eating
Disorders any video that condones
violence images of breastfeeding only if
child is actively nursing no nipples
allowed I didn't make this up yeah
that's actually true oh and here's this
is just fantastic let's look at this
image of Kylie manogue they banned this
image of her uh she's holding a bear
there and uh as you can see they said we
do not allow photos that contain nudity
drug use or violence now it appears that
the microphone looks like the Bear's
penis I suppose I haven't seen a bear
penis before but I guess that's what's
happening here and Facebook actually
took that picture down so does this just
sort of show the subjectivity and how
stupid when you have these big rules for
everybody on something as big as
Facebook how stupid these rules are
unless that did that turn you on in any
way I like that picture actually it was
a cute picture you know we had a story
on on Riot the other day that was about
uh the London Museum of artist having a
new exhibition of Japanese wood printing
block printing from the 1800s and there
was one of a a painting of a naked woman
and they pulled it off they banned me
for a day they banned our whole ad they
pulled Riot down for a day and it was a
painting from the 18th century on a of
like a a beautiful piece of Fine Art and
it was frustrating to me because I think
you know it was part of goes back to
part of our culture that is so afraid to
show nipp on a on a on a on a feed but
can absolutely show you know violence
and and and to me I would rather see
nipples on my feed than than blood any
day right absolutely me wrong we're all
agree about that that us we should start
a Facebook about that speaking of
nipples on Facebook I remember a couple
months ago there was a a portrait a
painting of B Arthur that was that was
sold for like $1.1 million on S bees and
they put the picture on there and they
took that down so it's even a painting I
don't think anyone's really looking at
BR painted
in a sexual way no it's it's totally
absurd I mean are you Max I'm
not but no I do think it's it's
ridiculous that you can't show you know
tasteful nudity on Facebook right so but
do you guys think it should be open for
everything I mean if if so when they're
showing these beheading things usually
it's to expose something awful that's
happening the last time that I
specifically remember it was with the
Syrian rebels uh beheading some people
and then it turned out maybe it wasn't
the rebels and that whole thing but
shouldn't Facebook just be open sort of
for what we all want to whatever it is
that we want you you select your friends
I don't know what I also don't know what
the point of it is I mean if you're
showing it and I also don't know how you
tell if you're condoning it or you're
celebrating or sadistic in the first
place I mean for us with our new site we
spend a lot of time at Riot like saying
look should we post this picture should
we not post this picture do people want
to see it and we have a young audience
our posts go up on Facebook so we're
really sensitive to that and people call
us out all the time if we put a Facebook
post that has a really bloody image on
it that happened with the Boston
Marathon I think a lot of people tried
to figure out how show those images
there I I always try to be sensitive to
it because if there's not at least an
action of how you can help that person
then what then it is statistic in that
ways you know so I don't know would you
rather it be open for everything just
for the because you're you're selecting
your friends people that you know that
are seeing it it is a cultivated and
sort of right I would never say that
they should censor you know anything
especially if if you know the the
pictures depicting violence do uh don't
condone violence in any way you know
they're they're being used to sort of um
say how awful it is but I personally you
know like I see a lot of things on my
Newsfeed about you know from animal
rights activists that are like pictures
of animals you know undergoing Viv
section and things like that and I it
turns me off you know I don't think that
that's the way to Rally people around
your cause by using you know um
inflammatory uh you know graphic imagery
you know it's it's just not you guys
ever have that watch those faces of
death videos when you were a kid I did
when I was like 12 my mom was not happy
I had one friend who always wanted to
have a sleepover and play those videos
and I like I didn't want to hang out
with that kid anymore he was the creepy
one I wanted to just watch like Child's
Play or something like that and this guy
wanted to watch those videos so I
unfriended him in real life before
Facebook that's a great if you don't
know what Faces of Death are it was B it
was lit it was real killings that they
showed on tape I don't know I was watch
I was having sleepovers watching that
too perfect very weird all right
well we've got a perfect segue from
what's going on on Facebook uh to
bullying which everyone's talking about
basically every day now and there was an
interesting opinion piece in the New
York Post uh suggesting that uh bullies
because of the way we're treating them
we're going to grow basically we're
going to grow a generation of super
bullies uh they said that one of the
reasons is because of Facebook post and
Twitter and Snapchat and kick and
everything else that we first off we've
separated the bully you used to have to
bully in person now you can bully
separate so that's sort of empowering to
the bullies and the second point that
parents are not as responsible as they
once were and kids are doing all kinds
of things and the parents are just
completely disconnected
because you know they don't see a kid
come home with a punched face or a
bruised knuckle uh and I thought it was
kind of interesting because everyone's
talking about bullying constantly uh
first off I kind of think that we need a
certain level of bullying I'm a little
worried about the NeverEnding bullies or
bad thing because when you get to the
real world there are bullies and if
you've never experienced it as a child
doesn't that set you up for a really
rough life that's a really interesting
take about it I mean I think that it's I
just came off as Pro bully but we
absolutely no I mean I think it's part
of look everybody has had bullies
forever growing up from the beginning of
time but I do think and you know with
with this sort of cyber bullying that
happens it's it's it's real and it's
legitimate and you can say anything to
somebody on on Twitter you can say
anything to somebody on Facebook I mean
when you read the kind of hate that's on
uh you know comments on on stories and
articles it's it's it's you know people
can hide behind that stuff if you were
to read the things that they're saying
about us right now below us it would be
right out yeah no about us I'm sure it's
all great no but really do do you think
it's any worse actually all the all the
Facebook stuff and Twitter stuff is all
is any worse than when we were in junior
high school and it happened to our faces
yeah because I think it's a lot easier
for cowards to hide behind the veil of
anonymity these days and just say
whatever they want and go completely
unchecked I think that like when you're
face to face there's still the
accountability of like okay well what if
the bully the kid that I'm bullying you
know has had two you know has had enough
and wants to punch me in the face like
that doesn't exist on the internet you
know right but didn't it happen where
people would you would write on the
Blackboard you know so max sucks and you
put that on the Blackboard and then
everybody would come in and see that you
get in a lot of trouble I feel like if
you did that so you know maybe there's
the same sort of uh you got to put the
same sort of rules do do you think part
of the problem is we've taken violence
so we we've shamed violence to the point
that in in the old days the old days in
the 1980s let's say like there were a
lot of parents I'm sure that would if
their son was getting bullied they would
have said well you got to just punch him
in the face and then he'll stop bullying
you and actually that really works most
of the time I think and now we're so
afraid of violence at all costs that we
we would you would never say that if you
were to say that to your kid now you'd
be shunned right if that came out that
you said to your kid punch the bully did
that ever work did the punch the bully
thing ever work I don't think it does
because I think that like you your
parents are like oh man you should stand
up and punch him and then he's a big
he's bigger than you CU in the first
place and it never happens like it does
in the movies where you one punch he
goes down the girl runs up I don't know
it never happened for me is that just a
movie so I'm so basically Biff in Back
to Future that's my main thing you know
you can't punch that guy you can't punch
that punch would never did it ever work
for you uh I or were you the bully I was
not the bully but I always uh Tred to
talk my way out of confrontations um and
I think that that's helpful you know I
think it's important to like to equip
children with creative faculty so that
they're able to like problem solve in
unique ways you know whereas so that
maybe like a punch isn't the only way
out of a situation you know yeah um
but I mean that is kind of why Carrie is
so gratifying right like she's like the
bullied girl who finally like gets back
at everybody in a horrific way right boy
yeah that seems extreme so so you're
endorsing lighting the other children on
fire pretty much lock but that I mean
Carrie's a pretty endearing story
because she's the girl who's like been
bullied her whole life you know and
comes from really you know horrible
background and I mean it's a horror
movie but uh I think there's other ways
though probably like you're talking
about with words maybe Carrie could have
come and you know worked with the
that's the method that I end not as
exciting of movie though especially for
Halloween time final thought on this how
how much should the parents actually be
responsible because this is the new
thing now we're hearing that a lot of
times the parents do know what's going
on and now people are trying to take
legal action against the parents because
they didn't stop the kid from bullying I
feel like that's a dangerous slope too
because parents can't be watching kids
all the time and unless they're
literally like coaching them on the
bullying I don't know how responsible a
parent could be for everything that a
child does right I mean you know I don't
know I feel like you got to really be
paying attention of course I don't have
any kids so it's easy for me to say like
no Facebook and Twitter when I'm don't
have to deal with it do your parents
know everything you're doing right now
yeah they do oh they're proud they're
writing the comments actually
anonymously are they I don't know
probably we'll find out yeah we will
what do you think do you think parents
can be held responsible for some of this
stuff I mean I I I think that it's a
parents job to just raise the kid with
values you know of kindness and and and
um you know empathy uh and to just teach
them to sort of spread that message you
know and and to again talk their way out
of things to give them like a creative
toolkit with which to solve problems
that helps that goes a long way all
right people when when you're commenting
on this please use your creative toolkit
what was another buzz word you said
there uh empathy empathy is a buzz word
these days and empathy use a little
empathy would you okay let's move on uh
oh I I thought this was fascinating so
Wikipedia which you guys know it's the
crowdsourced encyclopedia that we all
now go to for everything and basically
whenever you Google anything the first
thing that comes up is the Wikipedia
entry uh they've made an admission that
the site is being manipulated by PR
people and what they're calling sock
puppets uh who were using false
identities to change uh what we thought
were facts uh let's look at a quote from
the wikkipedia people it looks like a
number of user accounts perhaps as many
as several hundred may have been paid to
write articles on Wikipedia promoting
organizations or products and have been
violating numerous site policies and
guidelines including prohibitions
against sock puppetry and undisclosed
conflicts of interests that's Sue
Gardner who's the executive director of
the Wikipedia Foundation this has
nothing to do with real sock puppets I'm
pretty sure these are this is just a
term that they're using um this doesn't
really surprise me does this surprise
you guys at any level whatsoever no I
mean how is this now just becoming a
thing like anybody can edit a Wikipedia
profile anonymously even like how could
she say hundreds by the way I personally
could go and find hundreds that are
totally made up exactly but I I mean I
think it's interesting it's that that
that that when you look at Wikipedia
anybody can create those pages and you
know often times when I have somebody
who I'm interviewing or I'm meeting
somebody for the first time I look at
their Wikipedia page and it is always
just glowing this guy's the greatest
they best smile in elementary school and
I think that guy wrote that or his
girlfriend wrote it or whoever I don't
know yeah that's not surprising to me
right okay so we're all agreed this is
pretty obvious that this kind of thing
is happening so how dangerous is it this
the idea that just the general idea of
crowdsourcing facts because I feel like
nobody believes the government anymore
nobody believes the mainstream media so
now if we can't believe our crowdsource
facts who who do you believe actually
that that's the real question here who
do you really get facts from that you
feel like is an honest Arbiter of facts
besides besides me the young Church
Ruben report Riot of course acting
disruptive yeah I mean I who who trusts
Wikipedia in the first place it is a
great it's a great tool for you think a
lot of people do yeah but I mean you you
can see through some of it I suppose you
know but it's you never see something on
Wikipedia that's just really against
somebody else you know I mean it's
pretty straight up glowing occas you do
though and it's really interesting
sometimes sometimes you'll you'll read
something person your Wikipedia page my
wikip totally yeah a lot of hate a lot
of hate um yeah no it's it's shocking
that like that this is now just becoming
a thing I mean I thought that publicists
all the time went to Wikipedia pages and
I want to know who this community of of
regular Wikipedia editors are are okay
so let's talk about that so there are
250,000 volunteer editors that these are
the guys that are keeping tabs on this
whole thing uh so is that part of the
problem too so it's not only that anyone
can do it but then the the editing pool
250,000 people that's a crazy amount of
people again 250,000 and then only 200
are seem to be not accurate
in said 200 that should be 250,000 times
two that they make every single day for
their High School teacher the geometry
teacher the local Coach yeah okay so the
obvious answer then is that they have
you register somehow and prove your
credentials or something like that but
then isn't the danger in that that it
takes away there's something about the
anonymity of it I suppose are there's
something about the the general openness
that makes it what it is so that if you
make people register you're are you
going to lose something I'm not even
sure to me it seems like there's this
surprise about you know when when
somebody says what do you mean the you
know Facebook has privacy issues or
Twitter has privacy issues of course it
does or Google is actually looking
through your emails well of course it
does anybody who doesn't think think
that there's you know some sort of
privacy on the Internet or some sort of
you know objectivity with Wikipedia it's
just I think those people are coming
from it those are the guys who built the
Obamacare website the first the first
version of it so I'm you know I know for
people who grew up in the tech side I
don't think there's any surprise um and
you know who are these 250,000 people
who are editing these pages are they
professors are they Noble laurates I
mean I'm pretty sure they're I'm pretty
sure most of them are unemployed cuz who
what else would you do how else would
you have the time I don't do you have
the time to be Ed other people's
Wikipedia you I wish I had that kind of
time too yeah all right but so I sort of
alluded to this earlier but really how
much of this is sort of the government's
fault with the whole NSA thing because
we just don't trust our institutions
anymore I mean do really do you guys
trust just the basic besides R3 shows of
course I mean do you guys trust just the
basic I don't even trust NBC News you
know back in the day they would say if
you lost uh or in Vietnam if you lost
Walter kronite you lost America and it's
like who do you trust now that you would
actually turn something on and be like I
mean John Stewart I mean is is it us and
John Stewart h i mean I think it's
anybody's game and it's changing a lot
right now but certainly the traditional
media hasn't been working it's failed
people it's let a lot of people down and
that's why they're you know that's why
what you guys are doing is really great
and what Riot's trying to do is really
great as well and when you see you know
Vice doing their thing and BuzzFeed and
all those and Gawker showing up and
doing great reports I think
investigative journalism maybe hopefully
is coming back uh What Glenn Greenwald
is working on coming up I think it
should be a really interesting thing too
but yeah it has to change it can't just
be this corporate old media guard
anymore because people don't trust it I
got nothing to hand that was a pretty
good summation you got anything there no
all right pretty good okay well you're
GNA have something to talk about with
this one I think this is really really
great uh so Google engineering director
and futurist Ray KW believes we are
close to living in immortality and he's
working on it on his own body right this
second he takes 150 vitamins a day and
he's sort of broken down how he believes
he is going to live forever and he talks
about three Bridges so we're going to
break them down let's look at the first
one so Bridge one is to stay as healthy
as possible with diet and exercise and
current medicine okay that that seems
pretty standard nothing he's not
Reinventing the wheel right Eat Right
exercise okay pretty good bridge two is
the biotechnology Revolution where we
can reprogram biology away from disease
Max I know this is your department so
can you break down Bridge for us a
little bit Yeah Bridge 2 um you know
we're sort of at the cusp now where um a
lot of sort of Gene therapies the price
is coming down you know like you can
already have your entire genome decoded
you can go to 23andme.com
um so aside from Just Fitness and
Nutrition and supplementation we'll get
to a point where technology can actually
you know inter can actually intervene
and and cure a lot of the ills that
people are faced with from diseases to
aging itself um I think nanot
Technologies is involved in Bridge three
is that yes let's talk about Bridge
three Bridge three is to go beyond
biology to the nanotechnology Revolution
at that point we can have little robots
called Nanobots that augment your immune
system we can create an immune system
that recognizes all disease and if a new
disease emerged it could be reprogrammed
to deal with new pathogens uh Every Time
I Think of Nanobots it reminds me of did
you guys ever play Metal Gear Solid on
PlayStation or on Nintendo or something
it was all about nanobot I didn't I
didn't play that didn't play that great
great game all right played that he
obviously did um so literally robots are
going to be inside of us they're not
they're not going to look like robots as
we think of them today they're going to
be infinitely smaller than our iPhones
infinitely smarter and cheaper so you'll
actually the I mean they could in effect
take on like a fluidlike nature and you
inject yourselves with him and you have
got little Nanobots you know coursing
through your veins repairing damage at a
genetic level right and I think it's
really exciting okay so I don't want to
get too into the science of it CU I
think it's going to go over everybody's
head not your head but probably probably
our heads I'm already
lost but so is this the most natural and
human thing possible that we're using
science to extend life or is this the
reverse of that because dying is a part
of life boy that's a really big question
I got a big that's a good one take that
I mean for for me it's it's a pretty
exciting thing when you basically talk
about how you can reboot your whole
system and change you know he talks
about changing the operating system uh
and reprogramming it where you know you
can go in and turn genes on and off I
think that's how it works and so I mean
you know if you've lost loved ones from
something that's potentially uh uh
preventable by doing this I'm I'm I'm
down for it yeah you know yeah I mean I
think that people sort of when they hear
him you know say that he wants to be
immortal and cure aging that's when
people get weirded out I think that
that's an amazing thing to aim for you
know like who wants to age you know we
we sort of think of death as this thing
that's in the distant future but like
getting there requires like your joints
not working as well as they used to or
seeing your loved ones die you know and
I think that that's all horrible and I I
love where his heart is that he's trying
to sort of put an end to that but is
there something about the human
experience that then we could
potentially be losing if you can live
forever I mean we do have a circle of
life that has worked for you know the
fact that we covet life because it's
limited uh I don't think so you know
like Woody Allen says life gives meaning
to life not death you know but I also do
you know it does beg the question about
who you know gets access to these things
so then eventually it just becomes kind
of you know rich people or privileged
people or white people probably yeah but
the thing about technology is that it
lifts all boats you know like I think
that you know at the beginning some of
these Technologies usually are reserved
for you know the wealthier but I mean I
was talking about 23 and me at first
when that service launched it was $1,000
to decode your your DNA and now it's
either $99 or $199 it's like wildly
cheap right this watch that I'm wearing
right now is tracking all kinds of
Biometrics and it's $200 it's like
available what do we need to know what's
tracking our Biometrics or your
biometric mine it's got my heart rate is
tracking perspiration body temperature
it's pretty cool yeah and it's so cheap
yeah it's like so what does that tell
you though that just sort of is a
general I'm this healthy or something
well it's part of what people call the
Quantified Self movement you know the
more you can know about your biology the
better so that you can reprogram it you
can look out for certain things that
maybe your parents had that you don't
want to catch you know to me there was a
I when I was reading about what CW was
talking about this he said that there's
you know a very simple thing that we can
do right away which is almost to program
our gen to process fat to to process how
we you know uh uh you know get fat
basically so there's a there's a you
know he talks about in the very close
future where you'll just be able to take
a pill that basically helps you
metabolize so you can eat McDonald's and
crap but then just metabolize it
differently well because the way we
evolved we have this fat insulin
receptor Gene which holds on to
everything that we eat because there
might be a fast coming up there might be
a long period where we can't find any
food but that Gene today is obsolete
there's food everywhere right so why
wouldn't you want to like suppress that
Gene so that you could eat whatever you
want and your your old outdated
biological software doesn't want to just
hold on to it yeah now okay so I'm I'm a
big sci-fi guy and we've talked about
this on the show many times I'm a firm
believer that the robots will come and
destroy us one day or enslave us or some
kind of Terminator style stuff so if we
start putting these robots even though
they're not robots as we think of them
in our bodies I mean ultimately I see a
lot of there's a big window for a lot of
bad stuff to have I mean why can't they
just turn on us and all that that whole
thing Ry actually always us uses the the
metaphor of fire fire can either burn
you or cook your food you know it's it's
really up to humans to uh to dictate the
course of where technology takes us as a
species um but I'm optimistic like you
are and like you are I'm sure and you
know I think that like we'll make the
best of it we'll use it to cure aging
it's like it's when it gets complicated
when when business you know interferes
you know and and and you know a profit
motive is is what's pursued rather than
Innovation for Innovation um itself but
uh they do talk about these two
different ideas of Singularity one where
you know we sort of blend and become you
know half half man half robot and then
the other one where there is a moment
where since robots are contr artificial
intelligence shows up and is controlling
then what what need do they have for
humans anymore on the planet if we're
just sort of they're looking at us like
we're another part of the sickness or
disease that I can't start thinking
about CU wouldn't we just be like some
you know variable that can't be
controlled we would be a virus the
robots don't need us and then that's
that is that what that video game was
about or a different one was The
Terminator
that was the Terminator mostly but yeah
well I guess we've given you a lot to
think about here uh M are blown M's are
totally blown thanks to Max lug Brent
moer their uh Twitter feeds are right
Twitter feeds do people say feeds their
Twitter handles are uh right below don't
forget to subscribe you just got to
click it and uh then you're subscribed
and you'll just get the videos there you
go thanks for watching we'll do it again
next week hey guys don't forget the
Ruben reports brought to you by koa.com
they've got up to 75% off pet treats
toys and more and if you use code RR you
can get another 20% off that's a lot off
uh there is a link in the description
right down below code RR 20% off make
your pet
happy